good afternoon the u.s national security
advisor took to the white house podium
friday with an urgent sounding warning
any american in ukraine should leave as
soon as possible and in any event in the
next 24 to 48 hours
we obviously cannot predict the future
we don't know exactly what is going to
happen
but the risk is now high enough
and the threat is now immediate enough
that this is what prudence demands
he warned that these russian military
exercises could quickly turn into an
attack on ukraine possibly with bombings
and missile strikes and eventually a
ground invasion
russia has repeatedly denied its
intending to attack its neighbor but
with the current buildup of forces and
equipment along the russia ukraine
border the u.s believes it could and in
another sign of urgency a virtual
meeting friday morning between the u.s
president and his european allies nato
canada poland and romania
soon after the pentagon announced an
additional 3 thousand troops will be
headed to poland in the coming days on
top of the nearly 2 000 that are already
on the way in addition to the 1 000
soldiers deployed to romania u.s
president joe biden says while troops
will go to nato countries he's ruled out
sending any into ukraine if there is an
invasion still the u.s insists there is
still time to come to a diplomatic
solution the administration has taken
its concerns about russia you know very
publicly very earnestly very
forthrightly
and and there's a potential reward here
if putin eventually
takes an off-ramp and begins to
de-escalate
the white house has confirmed that
president biden and russian president
vladimir putin will speak on the phone
saturday a call that may provide a clear
picture of the likely path forward
patti calhane al jazeera washington